thank you
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the United States
good afternoon everyone
thank you thank you thank you
friends Partners speaker Pelosi members
of Congress who've traveled here to
represent the United States and fellow
leaders
it's an honor it's an honor to once
again participate in this critical
Summit
I'd like to thank our host president
CeCe for bringing us together at this
pivotal moment thank you Mr President
thank you
let me start by acknowledging that this
day is a day of commemoration at home in
the United States
it's Veterans Day
America's veterans and their families
survivors and caregivers are there a
spying and soul of the United States
and on this special day
on every day I honor all those who've
sacrifice through our nation like my son
I want to thank I want to thank one
proud American Veteran a lifelong public
servant and dear friend and literally
one of the most decorated men to fight
special Envoy for climate John Kerry
John
John may your passion new diplomatic
expertise have been absolutely critical
absolutely critical delivering
incredible progress on climate issues
over the past two years and I thank you
pal I thank you for being my friend
here in Egypt the Great Pyramids of the
ancient artifacts stand as Testament to
Millennia of human ingenuity
we see our mission to avert climate
catastrophe and seize a new clean energy
economy not only as an imperative for
our present and future but Through The
Eyes Of History
according to the world the world of
meteorological organization the past
eight years have been the warmest on
record
the United States and the United States
you're seeing historic drought and
wildfires in the west devastating
hurricanes and storms in the East here
in Africa here in Africa home to many
nations considered most vulnerable to
climate change food insecurity hunger
follows four years of intense drought in
the Horn of Africa
meanwhile the knights River in West
Africa swollen swollen because of more
intense rainfall is drinking habit on
fishing and farming communities
in Nigeria flooding has recently killed
600 people
1.3 million more are displaced
seasonal livestock migration routes have
been used for hundreds of years are
being altered
increasing the risk of conflict between
herders and local farming communities
the climate crisis is about human
security
Economic Security
environmental Security National Security
and the Very life of the planet
so today I'd like to share with you how
the United States
is meeting the climate crisis with
urgency and with determination to ensure
a cleaner safer and healthier plan for
all of us
from my first days in office
my Administration has led to the Bold
agenda to address the climate crisis and
increase energy security at home and
around the world
we immediately rejoin the Paris
agreement
we convened major climate Summits and
reestablished
I apologize never pulled out of the
agreement
we established major economic and major
economies form to Spur countries around
the world to raise raise their climate
ambitions
last year cop 26 in Glasgow the United
States helped deliver critical
commitments that will get two-thirds of
the world's GDP on track to limit
warming to 1.5 degrees Celsius
over the past two years the United
States has delivered unprecedented
progress at home
through a generational investment and
upgrading our nation's infrastructure
we're making up our power grid better
able to transmit clean energy
expanding public traffic Transit and
rail
building Nationwide network of electric
vehicle charging stations over 50 000.
and this summer the United States
Congress passed and I signed the law my
proposal for the biggest most important
climate bill in the history of our
country
the inflation reduction Act
it improves the lesson I asked for but a
significant amount
368 billion dollars
to support
clean electric clean electric
electricity everything from onshore
offshore wind to distributed solar zero
emissions vehicles and sustainable
Aviation fuels more efficient
electrified buildings cleaner industrial
processes and Manufacturing
climate smart Agriculture and Forestry
and more
look our department of energy estimates
that the new law will reduce emissions
in the United States by about 1 billion
tons in 2030 while unleashing a new era
of Clean Energy power and economic
growth
our investments in technology from
Electric batteries to hydrogen are going
to spark a cycle of innovation that will
reduce the cost and improve the
performance of clean energy technology
that will be available to Nations
worldwide not just the United States
we're going to help
make the transition to a low carbon
future more affordable for everyone
accelerate the carbonation beyond our
borders and in fact
the International Energy agency recently
concluded that our significant climate
investment will quote help Turbo Charge
the mer the energy the
excuse me turbocharged the emerging
Global clean energy clean energy economy
sorry
it's going to shift the Paradigm for the
United States the entire world
that I we also ratified the Kigali
amendment to Rally the world on phasing
down the production and consumption of
hfcs greenhouse gases but a thousand
times more damaging carbon dioxide and
just yesterday the United States became
the first government to require that our
fed our major federal suppliers disclose
their emissions and climate risks and
set targets for themselves that are
aligned with the Paris agreement
as the world's largest customer
with more than 650 billion dollars in
spending last year the United States
government is putting our money where
our mouth is to strengthen
accountability for climate risk and
resilience
these critical steps are already locking
in vital investments in our
infrastructure delivering lower costs
for clean energy spurring good paying
union jobs for American workers and
advancing environmental justice in our
communities
sorry
we're proving a good climate policy is
good economic policy is a strong
Foundation
for durable resilient inclusive economic
growth is driving progress in the
private sector
just driving progress around the world
and some total of the actions my
Administration is taking puts the United
States on track to achieve our Paris
agreement goal of reducing emissions 50
to 52 percent below 25 Levels by 2005
Levels by 2030.
let me just take a moment to emphasize
how meaningful
it is that I can say that
I introduced the first piece of climate
legislation in the United States Senate
way back in 1986.
36 years ago
my commitment to this issue has been
unwavering today finally thanks to the
actions we've taken I can stand here as
president United States of America and
say with confidence the United States of
America will meet our emissions targets
by 2030.
foreign
to do our part to avert the climate hell
that the U.N Secretary General so
passionately warned about earlier this
week
we're not ignoring harbingers that are
already here
it's true so many disasters climate
crisis the sitting hardest those
countries and communities that have the
fewest resources to respond and to
recover
that's why last year I committed to work
with our Congress to quadruple U.S
support to to climate finance and
provide 11 billion dollars annually by
2024 including three billion dollars for
adoption
that's why the Fund emergency plan for a
adaptation and
resilience prepare we call it to help
more than a half a billion people in
developing countries respond to climate
change
we're already requested more than 2
billion for the prepared this year
I'm going to fight to see that this and
our other climate objectives are fully
funded today
as a down payment we're announcing more
than 150 million dollars in initiatives
that specifically support prepares
adaptation efforts
throughout Africa including adaptation
in Africa effort that Egypt and the
United States launched together in June
this includes support for expanding
early Warning Systems to help cover
Africa broadening access to climate
Finance providing disaster risk
protection strengthening food security
mobilizing the private sector and
supporting new training center in Egypt
to accelerate adaptation across the
efforts all across the continent
mine was
my Administration has also made the
United States
the first ever contributor to the
adaptation fund last year and this year
we're doubling our pledge to bring in
our total commitment to 100 million
dollars we're also making sure that
every dollar we deliver goes as far as
possible unlike
unlocking larger pools of finance and
the trillions in private investment we
know that will be needed
folks we're also supporting the global
Shield a G7 initiative to better protect
vulnerable countries
everywhere from climate-related losses
and quickly respond to climate-related
damages
and the G7 LED partnership for Global
infrastructure and investment is working
to meet the critical infrastructure
needs in low and middle-income countries
with specific focus on climate
the project we're facilitating
is built on transparency partnership
the protections for workers and the
environment one of the many projects
already underway is a partnership
between American firms and the
government of Angola to invest two
billion dollars building new solar
projects in Angola
and everywhere and every like everywhere
in the world climate adaptation in
Africa is working toward energy
Transmissions as just means creating
good jobs spurring inclusive economic
growth and leaving no one behind as we
Implement a sustainable development
goals
folks now I know this has been a
difficult few years
the interconnected challenges we face
can feel all consuming
and the upheaval we're seeing around the
world especially Russia's brutal attack
against Ukraine is exacerbating food
shortages and energy spikes and cause
increasing volatility in those energy
markets driving up Global inflation
against this backdrop it's more urgent
than ever that we double down on our
climate commitments Russia's War only
enhances the urgency of the need to
transition the world off as dependence
on fossil fuels
true energy security means every nation
means that every nation is benefiting
from clean Diversified Energy Futures no
action
no action can be taken without a nation
understanding that it can use energy as
a weapon
whole the global economy hostage it must
stop
and so this Gathering must be the moment
to recommit our future and our shared
capacity to write a better story for the
world
let's build on our Global Climate
priorities raising both our ambition and
the speed of our efforts the science is
devastatingly clear
we have to make vital progress by the
end of this decade that's why the United
States is rallying the world around
climate game changers I launched one
such Game Changer last year in the
European commission president of
underline the global methane pledge
we started it with the EU and eight
other countries in Glasgow grew to more
than 100 countries now more than 130
countries have signed on to cover more
than half of the global methane
emissions methane is 80 times more
potent than carbon and it accounts for
nearly half half of the net warming
we're experiencing now
so cutting methane by at least 30
percent by 2030 can be our best chance
to keep Within Reach of 1.5 degrees
Celsius Target
today we're releasing an updated methane
emissions reduction act plan
which lays out how the United States is
meeting the pledge
we're investing more than 20 billion
dollars in domestic methane mitigation
to do things like capital or from Wells
leaky methane improving industrial
equipment and the oil and gas sectors to
reduce emissions
it also lays out strong regulatory
actions including including a new
proposal from our Environmental
Protection Agency to strengthen
standards on methane across sectors
especially from Super emitters to make
so just to make sure it's not released
in the communities impacted on public
health all told these steps
all told these steps to reduce U.S
method the U.S methane emissions
from covered sources by 87 percent below
the levels of 2005 by 2030. folks
another game changer it's conserving our
natural environment
whether it's the Congo basin's forest
and
Peak plants here in Africa or the Amazon
basin in South America
or Forest Wetlands grasslands in the
United States preserving nature is one
of the most impactful climate Solutions
we have
some that indigenous people who have
communities have known and been the
stewards of these efforts for a long
time and generations they've known it
here at cop27 we are co-chairing forest
and climate partnership to deliver real
rapid strides to Halt deforestation
the best part is we don't have to
develop any new technologies we just
have to make clear forests are more
valuable when they're preserved than
when they're destroyed
and those who are able to be chipping in
to help those countries in fact preserve
those great forests
we're bringing together Partners across
the public and private sector and
philanthropic sectors to put health
healthy ecosystem at the heart of
healthy economies
this is going to take all of us it could
take all of us we need to harness our
capacity to tackle emissions and
economic sectors like international
shipping
if the shipping sector were a
stand-alone economy for a standalone
economy it would rank as the 10th
largest emitter in the world
so together in Norway the United States
has launched the green shipping
challenge
during this cop we've seen dozens of
commitments from governments as well as
supports and private companies to
facilitate green shipping corridors and
online sector with the 1.5 degree goal
if we can accelerate actions on these
game changers we can reach our goal we
can keep it within reach as well but to
permanently bend the emissions curve
every nation has needs to step up
at this Gathering we must renew and
raise our climate ambitions the United
States has active everyone has to act
it's a duty and responsibility of Global
Leadership countries that are in a
position to help should be supporting
developing countries so they can make
decisive climate decisions
facilitating their energy transitions
building a path to prosperity and
compatible with our climate imperative
countries can Finance coal in developing
countries there's no reason why we can't
finance Clean Energy in developing
companies
thank you
we're pleased to announce today
alongside the European Union in Germany
a 500 million dollar package to finance
and facilitate Egypt's transition to
clean energy
this package will enable Egypt to deploy
10 gigawatts of renewable energy by 2030
while bringing offline five gigawatts of
inefficient gas powered facilities
reducing emissions in Egypt and power
sector by 10 percent
we also will also work with Egypt to
capture nearly 14 billion cubic meters
of natural gas which is currently flares
vents or leaks from its oil and gas
operations
and because of this cooperation Egypt
has elevated its climate ambition and
submitting enhanced National
determination contribution
if we're going to win this fight every
major emitter Nation needs to align with
a 1.5 degrees we can no longer plead
ignorance
to the consequences of our actions or
continue to repeat our mistakes
everyone has to keep accelerating
efforts throughout this decisive decade
my friends
I came to the presidency determined to
be attracted and make the transform of
transformational changes
that are needed
that America needs to make
and we have to do for the rest of the
world to overcome Decades of opposition
and obstacles of progress in this issue
alone to re-establish the United States
as a trustworthy committed Global leader
on climate
as I stand here before you we've taken
enormous stride to achieve that
[Music]
but I don't stand here alone
this progress is being driven by young
people all across America
like young people around the world they
feel the urgency of climate they feel it
deeply they're committed to these issues
they know the stakes and that's their
world were created this is not to stand
by and allow us to fail in various in
this responsibility we can
that's why as I look out
of all the things that I've accomplished
there's so much more to do I'm
optimistic for all the work that remains
to be done we have to put down
significant markers of progress
the United States has taken enduring
steps to meet our goals we're delivering
on our promise of leadership and more
and more the world is standing with us
so determined diplomacy is necessary
we're finding consensus building and
understanding and launching new
approaches
and the inspiring passion of young
people
Civil Society climate activists
indigenous communities is literally
galvanizing the world
yes challenge we Face are great but our
capacity is greater than the challenge
that we must never doubt that
so let's Reach Out
take the future in our hands and make
the world we wish to see
that we know we need
to plan a preserve for generations to
come an economy powered by Clean
Diversified secure energy sources
opportunities unlocked through
Innovation and cooperation to deliver
Equitable or prosperous more stable and
more just world for our children that's
why we're here
that is what we're working toward and we
can do it together I am confident thank
you thank you thank you may God bless
you all
foreign